والآن إلى بعض الصور المزعجة بشكل لا يصدق
حول كيفية تأثير الصراع بين
إسرائيل وحماس
في
مناطق أخرى، كان هذا هو المشهد الفوضوي في أحد
مطارات جمهورية
داغستان الروسية، حيث تظهر مقاطع الفيديو حشدًا كبيرًا من الناس
يقتحمون المطار ويصلون إلى
المدرج  بعضهم يلوح
بالأعلام الفلسطينية بعد وصول طائرة من تل
أبيب، والآن تظهر الصور التي تم التحقق منها بواسطة CNN
أشخاصًا ضمن الحشد يحملون
لافتات معادية للسامية، وتقول وزارة الصحة في داستان إن ما
لا يقل عن 10 أشخاص
أصيبوا بجروح خطيرة، وأغلقت السلطات
المطار وتجري الآن
تحقيقًا  كيفية ضمان أن يكون الأمر آمنًا
للمضي قدمًا وقد ناشد زعيم ديني محلي
الشركات، كما هو الحال بالنسبة لإجراءات اليوم، بالطبع
أقول بصدق أنك مخطئ في أن هذه
القضية لا يمكن حلها بهذه
الطريقة، وقالت إسرائيل إنها تعمل مع
السلطات الروسية لتأمين
البئر.  وجود يهود وإسرائيليين في
الموقع والولايات المتحدة تدعو روسيا لحماية
الإسرائيليين واليهود بعد هذا
الحادث تحذر الأمم المتحدة من أن أسابيع الحصار
والقصف أثرت على
غزة
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع وقال رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو إن بلاده
بدأت المرحلة الثانية من حربها
ضد
حماس، الحرب داخل القطاع
ستكون طويلة ونحن مستعدون لها،
هذه هي حرب استقلالنا الثانية
سنقاتل من أجل الوطن
ولن نسحب الضربات الجوية الإسرائيلية
بالفعل  ألحقت أضرار جسيمة بالمنطقة،
وتتهم جمعية الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني إسرائيل
بشن هجمات متعمدة بالقرب من ثاني
أكبر مستشفى في
مدينة غزة وفقًا
للنظام المدني التابع للأمم المتحدة، وهو يتقلص في غزة
ويقول المسؤولون الأمريكيون إن هناك فرصة
لهذه الحرب في غزة.  يمكن للشرق الأوسط أن يتوسع،
حماس تجعل الحياة صعبة للغاية
بالنسبة لإسرائيل من خلال اتخاذ المدنيين كدروع بشرية
ومن خلال وضع
بنيتها التحتية الصاروخية والبنية
التحتية الإرهابية بين المدنيين مما
يخلق عبئًا إضافيًا على إسرائيل، حيث بلغ
عدد القتلى في غزة من هذه الحرب أكثر
من 7900 حتى الآن.  الأحد وفقًا
لوزارة الصحة الفلسطينية، أنا تقرير جون
لورانس